a housing view of the world where I come  from not all that glitters is gold just  like with Chinese food which I love as  much today as they did as kid  it is so colorful and diverse it doesn't  matter where I am it always reminds me  of home for me there is nothing better  The Mikado and started to talk after  decades of living in Germany Chinese  food is one of the things I miss the  most but by taking a step back  I see things a little differently now  many of food-processing regulations that  exist the other part of the world  haven't been implemented in China that  leave a lot of Chinese people wondering  if their food is safe to eat for them  and their shooters but people have a  right to learn oh it really is this is  the job of journalism how I see it and  that is why I love my job because I try  to do exactly this every day my name is  Allen tool and I work at GW  [Music]